so with everything that's going on I've
come to the conclusion that I have not
been getting enough sleep lately so I am
making an effort to be less woke wow
you're really gonna open with that are
you okay then let's talk about the
complaints of woke miss in entertainment
this this won't be controversial at all
especially with most of my subscribers
being Doctor Who fans because this
definitely hasn't been any kind of
sticking point in that band um you know
the curse to me actually between this
and the positive masculinity video that
I did last month I've kind of been
branching out from the usual lgbtq+
specific videos so far this year that
hasn't really been intentional but I
guess it's it's just where my mind has
been going lately topics that are in the
same zip code but not exactly the same
neighborhood don't worry we'll get back
to our usual queer gathering soon enough
Shh don't tell the straights so the
reason that this has come up for me is
because it's one of those times where I
have just gotten sick of seeing the same
hollow infuriating comment masquerading
as an argument over and over and over
again so I am hoping that by addressing
this nonsense in video form will mean
that I'll get it out of my system and
won't have to keep thinking about it it
has yet to actually pan out that way for
these things but host brings eternal and
I can be a right stubborn bastard so I'm
about to throw you out some examples of
what I've been dealing with and they are
largely going to be referencing Doctor
Who because that's what I talk about the
most but if you browse the comments of
my videos or indeed the comments on
nearly anything discussing film
television topics video games etc then
you've probably seen a few gems along
the lines of
what a load of rubbish tenant dies for
Wilf and old men and this doctor woke
ran away this totally goes against all
canon it's called doctor who can't even
call it that anymore this is BBC agenda
at its peak this will lose so many more
fans your logic is flawed because chips
and code do not have to explain a damn
thing we would like them to Reva fans
have much more imagination and
creativity in our collective little
finger than Chibs and Coe have plain and
simple Chibs and Coe are too busy
pushing an agenda to imagine a
believable explanation what is to be
gained with the gender swap the same
argument you did here can be there plus
it is agenda and not story driven I've
been a fan of the show for ages seen
every episode including the classics and
the audio episodes even built myself a
full-sized TARDIS and k9 the show is now
I can't watch it anymore
it's so painful the show used to be
sci-fi not awoke soap opera absolute
garbage Doctor Who ain't good sci-fi
story anymore it's there to shoehorn the
BBC's PC left-wing agenda
it's beyond woke now for someone writing
for the so called woke sjw community
Chibnall makes the doctor look totally
redundant
I actually prefer hell-bent Chiba has
said he cares not for Canon and we'll
have our noses rubbed in woke I couldn't
agree less if it was canceled that would
be one fewer pieces of walk lefty
propagandized crud available to
brainwash our kids and secure a more
insecure divisive and dangerous future
for us all
rest in peace Doctor Who
you gave us decades of fantastic stories
and adventures who has become a bit of a
pattern I'm sure you noticed it's bad
because it's sgw pander or left-wing
agenda or woke now all of these terms
are euphemisms for racial gender or
sexual diversity as well as any core
message that is currently classified as
being even slightly politically
left-of-center so pretty much any time
anything acknowledges the existence of
somebody who is in white heterosexual
cisgender able-bodied or is a woman
filling a traditionally male function
tends to get mockingly stamped by the
tractors as woke and look the labeling
is what it is there are people who for
reasons that escape me personally find
these things inherently offensive and
there isn't much that I or anybody can
do about that fact you can't make people
change what bothers them like that and
I'm not gonna try no so what is that I'm
fed up with is how woke or progressive
or agenda-driven or a politically
correct or whatever
of course the by now vintage chestnut of
sjw pandering I hate that those terms
get thrown out as thought terminating
cliches those are phrases that get said
in order to shut down the conversation
and rely entirely on the idea that these
things are inherently bad and that
anything that can be associated with
them is also bad and therefore once the
label is applied no more discussion is
required
it's an Intel it's an anti intellectual
argument because it actively discourages
the conversation and it's also a
coward's tactic the point of any
thoughts are many in cliche is to have
the appearance of winning an argument
without actually making any kind of
substantive case for your perspective it
has the appearance of winning because
those who disagree tend to take hearing
these terms as signals
that the discussion has hit a wall and
there's little point in progressing so
they I would think wisely disengage and
then the anti PC Brigade declares
victory by default because well if the
other side left it must be because you
won right I had an interesting bit of
validation in relation to all this
actually earlier this year when I went
to the Doctor Who convention Gallifrey
won before everything went to hell
because I got into probably about a half
a dozen conversations with people who
were clearly unhappy with what they felt
was a trend of locusts in Doctor Who in
recent years and I say that those
conversations were validating for me
because they were perfectly reasonable
calm polite conversation absence of
these thought terminating cliches and it
confirmed my long-held suspicions that
in comments sections and Twitter and
similar cesspits people will dig in and
argue dirty but when talked to in person
they dropped the performative
stonewalling and are capable of not only
absorbing nuance but providing it as
well now I don't have the time to
actually sit down for one-on-one
conversations with all of these people
so let's get into why the whole woke
automatically equals bad notion is just
a flat-out garbage argument it's not
what a movie is about it's how it is
about it let's be very clear there is
such a thing as bad pieces of
entertainment bad movies back comics bad
TV shows bad video games though works
and there is plenty of bad entertainment
that fits the mocking label of woek but
it's not bad because it's woke it's bad
because it's bad the recent Doctor Who
episode orphan 55 is a bad piece of
television with a core environmentalist
message to it but the reason it's bad is
because it shifts awkwardly between
story acts suffers from directionless
performances from the supporting cast it
gives us creatures that only look good
in the dark and then puts them in broad
daylight it places its reveal at a very
pointing the structure of the story and
that waits until the last two minutes to
try and slam home its message with the
subtlety of a carbide drill to the taint
it's not bad because of what its message
is or the mere existence of a
progressive message in the first place
but because of how badly it's executed
on the standard nuts and bolts that all
visual storytelling is judged on how do
I know that because it's got the exact
same twist is the original Planet of the
Apes and it's making nearly the same
point and Planet of the Apes is a
classic that holds up to this day
because it nails everything that orphan
55 Boches great acting tightly paced
script affects carefully shot to hide
their limitations and a hero with a
personal character arc so the revelation
can hit him directly in a way that is
completely consistent with what we know
about the man and it never feels like
he's stopping to talk directly to the
screen despite the fact that it ends
with him literally yelling damn you all
to hell at Humanity of the 20th century
aka the audience watching it's good
because it nails the execution also a
tangent bringing up a movie from the
1960s lets me at least touch on the fact
that people who deploy be you woke
therefore bad argument also tend to
imply if not outright state that its
message and attitudes and this whole
progressive thing is somehow new or at
least the insertion of them into fiction
is something new and recent and that's
also nonsense I've talked about that
specifically in regards to Doctor Who
before but in fiction in general in
science fiction specifically which right
now a very high percentage of mainstream
entertainment is self is some form of
has always been dominated by progressive
messaging you do get the occasional
conservative voice from figures like
Robert Heinlein but they are clearly the
minority in the genre and always have
been the inherent nature of science
fiction is built to comment on the
present by speculating about the future
or at least future style tech that is
what the genre is
or as I said I talked about this in
regards to Doctor Who over two years ago
so check out that video if you want to
and you want more details on that okay
tangent over call me back on topic that
quote from Roger Ebert may be one of the
most important things to keep in mind if
you ever want to make meaningful
criticism agreeing or disagreeing with
messaging as a matter of opinion but
regardless there is still a level of
craft and polish that results in a good
final product and to show that this is
not just the anti PC Brigade needing to
separate ideology from quality and
instead this whole thing goes both ways
I'm gonna talk about a couple films with
messaging that is distinctly not
progressive what I'm about to say is not
exactly a widely held belief over here
among us sjw's but I think the movie 300
is straight-up a great film
I don't agree most of its core messages
and when you put it into the context of
things that Frank Miller who was the
writer of the original comic that it's
based incredibly faithfully on things
like he has said since then and also
written I do honestly wish I could say
that it's a bad movie I would feel
better if I could say that but I can't
cuz it's not it's precisely presented
with perfectly pitch performances
exquisite I can be expertly evoke
emotions through carefully constructed
courage confronting crowds of colossal
chaos I should apologize for that a
litter of alliterative mess but I won't
I'm proud of that
my point is though people can very
reasonably find that film uncomfortable
offensive even detestable nobody is
obligated to like it and I wouldn't
argue that anyone who didn't like it
should I would however push back on
claims that is politics make it an
actively bad film because they don't be
honest about what it is you're
criticizing with something like 300
you're not criticizing a badly made film
with uncommitted acting or superfluous
story threads are incomprehensible
action editing it is a well-made film
with a mindset you
may not like and that's fair but just be
honest about that being your issue being
about that doesn't decide its quality
it's not what it's about
it's how it is about it execution is
what determines quality after that it's
a matter of taste now of course some
well and probably have already argued in
the comments that the woke this is what
leads to the bad execution now this is a
mildly more sophisticated argument but
not by much a hypothetical example goes
something like this
that actor of color in that part didn't
give a good performance and the reason
they got the part over a better
qualified white actor is because of PC
agenda woke Ness so people are basically
arguing when they deploy this against
what they perceive to be a form of
entertainment affirmative action which
is a bit of a bizarre argument as though
there's never been a miscast white actor
before or as though every other POC
actor who might have been cast would
have delivered the exact bad performance
one bad performance from a quote unquote
diversity hire
gets manipulated into an argument -
never diversify the caster crew again
although strangely a bad performance
from a sis het white male actor never
gets painted at sea this is why we
should be hiring white actors I say
strangely but it's not that strange
because white straight cisgender and
usually male is the template it's the
default that all characters are presumed
to be and less necessitated by the story
or otherwise indicated I've brought it
up before that the less presentation
there is of any given group the more
intense the scrutiny of the few bits of
representation that do exist and with
far fewer examples especially within
certain genres or franchises one or two
diverse characters are suddenly carrying
the weight of not only their demographic
but of every diverse demographic
everything that isn't cisgender
heterosexual white and traditionally
masculine all gets lumped again together
under other
and suddenly a bad performance from a
person of color becomes a reason not to
cast a transgender actor see what
happens when you deviate from the
template now to be clear there are times
that creators or corporations actually
do quite a bit to contribute to the
perceptions that fuel these arguments
and just before I sat down to record
this Marvel Comics gave a pretty much
perfect example of that earlier this
month they announced the launch of a new
iteration of the superhero team the new
Warriors with an all-new cast of
characters and this lineup is
excruciatingly ly painful for a number
of reasons all stemming from how
blindingly obvious it is that the
company and the writer by the name of
Daniel kibble Smith are desperately
trying to appear hip to the youth now to
be fair the book isn't out yet but the
concepts alone have already drawn
serious backlash from the intended
audience especially run the characters
of the twins who are named safe space
and snowflake yes
you did hear me write safe space and
snowflake and snowflake is not binary
because of course they are let's be
clear this is pandering and it is bad
because of how hard it is pandering but
it is not bad because of who it's
pandering to if these twins were instead
named edge Lord and rational skeptic in
an effort to appeal to the opposite side
of the presumed culture war they would
still be painful characters conceptually
people will call things pandering to
sjw's and as we clearly see that's
sometimes even accurate but then they
decide to blame the audience that's
being pandered to rather than the
practice of the pandering itself because
bad pandering is bad pandering even if
you're the demographic that is being
pander to and even beyond this example I
know a ton of you have already started
compiling lists of all the bad
properties that are woke remind
yourselves if you're doing that of the
fundamental principle of data analysis
correlation is not causation
there is woek entertainment there is bed
entertainment they do overlap at times
but they are not synonymous for
comparison and just stick with comics
for a little bit longer because I feel
like I don't talk about them enough from
the late 80s through was kind of hurt to
pin down what I actually started easing
off but at least for the entirety of the
90s the comic book industry had
essentially the same problem inverted
everything was trying to be edgy dark
and gritty and a lot of it was bad but
it would be lazy to say that things like
Youngblood bloodshot the 90s version of
Punisher and so much more were bad
because of being edgy dark and gritty
because there were good comics that were
also those things heck the entire trend
was kicked off by Watchmen and The Dark
Knight Returns which are both definitely
all three of those things and are also
both great the bad comics of the 90s
were bad because they were badly drawn
poorly thought-out and shallow because
they were being made by creators who are
more interested in jumping on a
bandwagon then doing their own thing and
finding their own unique voice and if
that bandwagon
instead of being dark edgy and gritty
had been rainbow colors and the power of
friendship they would have jumped on
that instead and done it just as badly
those were the strong artistic vision
can shine through even if their work is
part of a trend Watchmen holds up
Sandman
holds up the max holds up I'll even go
to bat for the first few years of spawn
regardless of the trends but cream rises
to the top because it's not the trend
that is the problem it is the chasers
who aren't inherently drawn to the
material but instead want to cash in or
are being told to cash in by the people
who sign their checks they are the
problem so even if you want to call a
piece of woke media trend chasing
because honestly it may well be that
still won't be what makes it good or bad
so look beyond whatever trend you think
it's being pandered to to find actual
reasons that it doesn't work because if
it's actually bad they won't be that
hard to find but if all you've got to
fall back on is sjw agenda Lal then
maybe you don't actually have an
argument that's worth making and if you
feel like I'm calling you out please
take this to heart I'm not trying to
tell you to shut up I am challenging you
to back up your assertions because even
if I disagree with your conclusion if
you put in the work I can at least
respect that much there just doesn't
seem to be a lot of work being done and
it's the laziness and the lack of
self-reflection when I see these
arguments that annoys me more than
anything else and above all in comments
on Twitter and in life please just don't
be an act all hey everybody thanks for
watching I hope you will subscribe share
this video and of course feel free to
leave a comment I actually do enjoy
getting them just you know try and
formulate an actual argument if I'm
gonna try and disagree with me I also
have a patreon if you want to help the
channel grow into bigger and better
things there's other links in the
descriptions beside that for you to
check out but you also don't have to do
any of it cuz at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meeting and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]